what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like all of the signs right
now point to the fact that Jonathan
Majors May no longer be our King in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now this is
obviously really big news and we're
gonna dive into it but we also have some
Moon night season 2 News to go over
today and also some Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 ending News James Gunn has
come out on Twitter talking to some of
the fans that have been tweeting at him
and he has clarified one very specific
thing in regards to the high
evolutionary who I think was just an
absolute great villain in that movie go
ahead and let us know what you thought
about him as the villain in Guardians 3
in the comments down below and of course
speaking of villains like I mentioned it
does seem like Jonathan Majors might be
out as king the Conqueror in fact today
we have a report that they re-wrote some
parts of Loki season 2 to essentially
write out his specific variant and we're
gonna explain what exactly this means
for the MCU in this video and a big
shout out to our new patrons the proud
Canadian AKA Jared La Rochelle critical
Cactus Crystal baitler and Eddie Johnson
thank you all so much for your support
we super appreciate it also we have a
giveaway going we'll talk about that at
the end of the video so we did a video a
couple of days ago talking about some
major updates with Jonathan Majors you
can check that out we'll link it down
below but if you missed it basically
what you really need to know is that
Marvel Studios and Disney have seemingly
removed all traces of Jonathan majors's
name and his character King the
conqueror's name from pretty much all
promotional material for Ant-Man and the
wasp quantumania and Loki season 2. his
name is still mentioned in the credits
obviously because well you have to do
that but anything else it's pretty much
gone even in quantumania they mentioned
that there is a threat they don't even
say King the Conqueror Kang the
Conqueror nothing really any association
with Jonathan majors and Kang is simply
not there right now so on the surface it
really really does look like Marvel
Studios is at least preparing to part
ways with Jonathan Majors as king they
could be waiting to see what happens in
the court where they've already had one
meeting but it didn't really go anywhere
yet but they could just be waiting to
see what happens with the case of
Jonathan Majors if he is found guilty or
innocent however removing him and even
the mention of his character from
basically all their promotional material
does say that they are at least
extremely worried and according to
Insider Alex B from the cosmic circus
Disney kind of issued a statement that
says under no circumstances are they
allowed in any of the material to
mention Jonathan Majors or his
involvement in Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania as king or the MCU in
general so that's a pretty big thing for
Disney to do however Alex P also
confirmed that of course they are not
going to Simply get rid of Kang they're
too deep into it and he is pretty much
the whole basis of the Multiverse Saga
and they stressed how super important
King was obvious slate and Loki season 1
and in quantumania and he's going to be
a huge part of Loki season 2. and this
is where it gets pretty interesting Alex
P also said that at the end of Loki
season 2 we're going to find out
Marvel's decision so it seems like
Marvel has already made their decision
and if you take a look at what is
happening at Disney and Marvel right now
that decision seems to be cutting ties
with Jonathan Majors however today we
have a new development coming again from
Alex B he tweeted out stating that they
have done reshoots for Loki season 2 and
this is because of the legal trouble
that Jonathan Majors is in Alex won't
State what the reshoots are to not get
in trouble which I understand however if
we simply use logic here we could pretty
much understand that if Marvel Studios
plan to keep Jonathan Majors they would
not do reshoots you really only do
reshoots if you plan on changing some
things plus Alex B said that at the end
of Loki season 2 and this of course was
with Alex knowing they did reshoots
already we would have our answer so that
would seemingly firm that the reshoots
war tube kind of right Jonathan Majors
as king out of the picture out of the
Multiverse Saga but let's just super
clarify this right now they are not
writing Kang out of the MCU they are
simply writing the variant that is
Jonathan Majors out of the MCU now I
know in quantumania's post-credit scene
we saw thousands of Jonathan Majors as
variants of King but Loki and especially
Spider-Man no way home taught us that
not all variants look the same so
basically whoever they bring in as a new
actor to play Kang is of course not
going to look like Jonathan Majors I'm
sure the actor they'll bring in will
have some similarities to him especially
in the acting Department you would
imagine that he would act pretty similar
but it's pretty easy to explain a change
in the actor one everybody kind of knows
what's going on right now with Jonathan
Majors but two as far as the continuity
of the actual Marvel Cinematic Universe
that world it's very easy to Simply say
well that was a variant of Kang yes
there are other variants like him
however this new one that is going to
come in in the Kang Dynasty or whatever
next Marvel movie he shows up in it's
pretty easy to say this one actually
with the new actor this is the man king
this is the main one you have to worry
about in the Kang Dynasty and in secret
Wars then all you have to do is have
scenes or post credit scenes with other
variants looking like him the new actor
unfortunately for Jonathan Majors it's
not really that big of a problem I mean
take a look at Iron Man 1 and then Iron
Man 2 Roadie was recast he was
originally Terence Howard but now it's
Don Cheadle and Don Cheadle has come so
far in the MCU he has been a part of
pretty much every major Avengers movie
now he's going to be in secret Wars and
even getting his own movie armor Wars
and although Jonathan majors has showed
up a lot more than Terence Howard did if
they have to recast they have to recast
it is what it is and although no
official statement has been made from
Marvel based off of all the information
that we've learned it does really seem
like they have decided to recast him but
we'll have to wait and see but in the
meantime let us know thoughts about all
of this in the comments down below now a
really cool report that we've heard
recently from deadline a couple of days
ago is that Marvel Studios is expected
to have big plans for May calamari who
played Layla AKA The Scarlet Scarab in
Moon Knight so since Marvel Studios has
pretty big plans for her this would
almost kind of confirm that Moon Knight
season 2 is coming we've heard rumors
about this for a pretty long time
insiders have said that it is happening
and Oscar Isaac has mentioned that he is
totally down to do it again which
obviously why wouldn't he and let's be
honest we know Marvel Studios has plans
for Moon Knight this wasn't just a one
and done Series in which we'll never see
Moon Knight again he's definitely coming
back and now that deadline has announced
that Marvel Studios has really big plans
for the Scarlet Scarab that pretty much
confirms season two and if they are
hearing things about these Moon Knight
characters that means that Marvel
Studios is probably trying to get the
ball rolling with that season 2. who
knows if it's going to come out before
the end of the Multiverse Saga or if
it's going to come out in Phase 7 but of
course course we hear anything we'll let
you know and as far as the ending of the
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is
involved with the high evolutionary
James Gunn has come out on Twitter and
he has confirmed the high evolutionary
is still alive we saw that Rocket
Raccoon refused to kill him however it
looked like the guardian simply let the
high evolutionary die at the end with
the Shipwreck but James Gunn confirms
that that is not true in fact he
confirms that Drax saved the high
evolutionary and when it comes to Rocket
not killing the high evolutionary this
is what James Gunn said yes it's the
whole culmination of Rocket's Journey
his shift comes in that he doesn't kill
him he goes from being the least
empathetic to the most empathetic
Guardian it seems silly and Hollow that
he'd refuse to kill him and then leave
him on an exploding ship and yes there
is a deleted scene it's really great
actually but it messed up the pacing of
the end but you'll see it in the extras
eventually and as far as where he is
right now James Gunn stated he is
imprisoned on nowhere so the current
Guardian of the Galaxy actually have the
high evolutionary and normally I would
say that that's a pretty big setup for
something to happen down the line
however this is James Gunn's story and
James Gunn is now out he is over at DC
now he is done with his own Guardians of
the Galaxy Trilogy and we have a new
Guardians of the Galaxy team so we'll
have to wait and see on that but for
those of you who were wondering the high
evolutionary is not dead he's very much
alive and he is on nowhere under the
watch of the Guardians of the Galaxy so
go ahead and let us know what you think
about all of this news in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and don't forget to subscribe and
leave a comment to enter our giveaway
for a chance to win one of the following
a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items winner
gets to pick and we pick a winner at the
end of each month also we now have a
website where we do updates daily
thecosmicwonder.com we have a patreon
account and a Discord server so I'll
link those down below if anybody is
interested you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
foreign